il y a bien longtemps j'ai moi-même été
aveuglé par l'amour
regarde tu observes ce qu'il reste de
moi
peux-tu me dire quel est ton souhait
quant à l'amour je pense qu'une fois
qu'on a fait fortune il n'est plus si
difficile à trouver et ce qui devait
arriver arriva un garçon comme un
aujourd'hui devenu un homme
d'innocent petit moment avant que ne
commence la grande corruption
je cherche un garçon répondant au nom de
pipe car je ris
maman
datée que je l'instruis
me quoi
on est pratique immorales de cette ville
immorale tu trouves de l'amour oui
monsieur Jagger souhaiterait que vous
restiez sous ma protection
le diable va venir
tu peux lui briser le cœur
et la seule chose qu'elle m'a prise
c'est comment briser le cœur des autres
je suis l'arme de sa vengeance
tout de même pas épouser cet abruti si
vous voulez vraiment avoir Estelle il
vous faudra plus que de l'amour
je suis bien mes consignes
j'espère que vos nouvelles bottes sont
imperméables allons-nous marcher dans
l'eau non nous traverserons
des marques de sang
[Applaudissements]
cette précieuse créature et ce qui
s'appelle une bonne prise
[Musique]